i had a conversation with my grandfather
and i was like oh
and i should have paid attention
because he warned me
now my grandfather still to this day for
me top five funny person i remember this
dude was just straight up funny but he
also had no
line of what was okay to say to a child
so we had a lot of weird conversations
you know
but this is my favorite one of all time
okay
so i'm eight
eight
you guys are me you're the back seat of
the car okay he sits down in the front
seat so this is all this is all i see
you guys are made i just see him go
you did that over
and he goes no it is wait till you get
older and you have to hold him in your
hand so you don't poop on him i was like
what the [ __ ]
take me to the jungle
[Music]
why is this a conversation between us
[Laughter]
and i'll tell you man
after seeing these old dudes naked all
the time
my my idea about viagra and all that
[ __ ] has changed and i'll tell you why
after seeing this old dude's body i'm
assuming women age the same way it's not
good for any of us
but i was assuming we're all aged the
same way and i don't know if our
genitals stop working
actually after seeing this old dude
thank you at some point i just think two
old people stand in front of each other
i don't know if my dick works but my
[ __ ] eyes do so
come on whatever that is
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you know how the story goes another
day another dollar howler 7 pm once
again i'm breaking up the bugs